6 à 10 ans accrobranche franchement je
pense que c'était un truc pour de rien
mais c'est et ça fait super dur oui
c'est super bien enfin gdgt comme ça on
l'a vu allez on va à sion par contre
nous c'était les vacances mais vous
votre entrée était assez spectaculaire
quand même un petit bébé
[Applaudissements]
tout est dit et on a pu réciter mes
chroniqueurs vous faire un joli cadeau
que je vais vous méritez non mais bon
avec un mot qui vient du coeur et la
vérité on sait pas mon travail
[Applaudissements]
je pose la question au cas où ce n'est
pas une boîte piégé ne pourrez pas vous
faire ça ah oui non mais c'est pas dans
son jour non mais franchement dans ces
nuls bah non c'est un garçon que j'ai
besson
[Applaudissements]
on
un petit but bah oui bah oui alors là
oui là c'est nuit-là il adore c'est ma
femme qui donne le sein j'adore rouler
alors pourquoi c'était alors c'est
encore un peu grand pont mais je vais
attendre pour lui m parce que voilà
merci ça lui ferait bien de saxon son
père s'est travesti dans sa jeunesse
belda parcours alors ça par contre ça
j'aime beaucoup le pic alors ça c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon